so this is gonna be my launching point
okay but I need to rewrite this a little
bit now the thing is there is a t of
them
I just haven't written it so it's
obvious right what is velocity after its
DX for DT right so there's a DX of DT
hiding you know you might say but that's
very good this is not with respect to
time you're right but you can turn this
thing upside down and work with it okay
so let me rewind a little bit it's come
back to this the first thing I want to
do is turn this introduces part because
the first thing I've got to do is
actually get a velocity but you know
it's not a forces squared function okay
so square root X this is kinda weird
this is kind of weird because if I put
in a position for X right this is
currently situation is currently telling
me I have two velocities and they're
going now I'm not going for quantum
physics and superposition at the moment
it should only be one velocity for this
object okay so which one is it so I have
some more information which I can
squeeze out of these initial conditions
do you notice this this which I've
already used actually gives me a sign to
notice that like ah when x equals 1
that's what it is not this or the
positive it's probably this one right so
I can say out of this but when x equals
1 I'm gonna I'm just gonna say it again
even though I've said it like three
lines earlier I'm invoking it again for
a different reason right so if you like
even I could have said V is negative
that's the important thing to me of that
negative root truth that it's negative
okay therefore they must be this case so
makes it
okay this is good this is progress right
remember we said now we've got our
actual velocity function velocity is
after all the X on DT now what I've got
up the right-hand side here this is
minus the square root of 2x cubed it's a
bit of a mess I'm gonna write it a
little bit differently
that's an index form anyone suggests to
me Y index four might be a handy thing
to use I'm about to integrate this right
before I integrate by the way there's
one more thing I have to do I have to
take the reciprocal right
I can't integrate with respect to time
though because this is not with respect
to time so I'm going to take the
reciprocal that's gonna allow me to
access this with respect to displacement
that's good reciprocal f means
reciprocals of right right so I'm gonna
get a minus one on root 2 what happens
to the index to the power if you take a
which is the cosine so the reciprocal of
X if index for right is X to the
negative one across the line change the
sign that business okay so the
reciprocal next to the three and two is
not extra two thirds that's making that
the reciprocal I want the reciprocal the
whole thing which is X to the negative 3
on 2 okay easy trap to fall into can you
tell that I fall in this before all
right now what I do this I want to know
this is interesting right because I'm
trying to get to X as a function of time
the next thing I'm gonna do is not gonna
give me X as a function time it's gonna
give me as a function of X but that's
okay cuz I have lots about inverse
functions right I've been working with
these things back and forth if I can get
T as a function of X I should be able to
go in the other direction okay so let's
do it you're going to integrate over
there on the left
just be careful here that minus one over
root two it's just the constant so I'm
just gonna write that there tell me what
to do with this
okay I'm going to raise the power by 1
and I divide by that new power right
dividing by negative 1/2 should be the
same as multiplying by a negative 2 do
you agree with that did I do it right so
I've got some negatives that cancel 202
of course is just root 2 and this is
well that's on what do you think ah yes
thank you okay so I've done my
integrating it wasn't indefinitely to go
there were no boundaries anywhere so now
I have to try and work out this second
constant how do I do that ah-ha sorry
this this little line here right this is
so much packed into it right you could
really squeeze a lot out you've got a t
equals 0 and an x equals 1 that you can
use at the same time right so this just
clip point out like three quantities but
we've consistently use them for
different reasons at different
combinations right so let's go ahead and
evaluate when T equals 0 x equals 1
therefore what do we got here two on one
yeah
yeah okay
so therefore time is right - on 3x
takeaway root - okay
so excellent we noticed yes we're not
finished we have times the function of X
I want X as a function of time so what
would you like me to do next
Maria race yeah okay so I'm gonna add
root 2 to both sides
that'll give me I might as well put this
on the left because that's where it's
gonna end up t + 2 now what we're not
going to do I'll take the reciprocals
get used to taking reciprocals and
checking that you're doing it right as
well like why things like this are easy
to muck up now what just multiplexer and
one last step
fantastic okay we got there right I got
basically as a function of X I use that
as my bridge right remember I said to
you okay when you see parts they almost
always I trying to lead you in a
particular direction and getting V
squared is the step to get a V and
working out which which one is the
actual case um briefly describe the
mission briefly describe the mission
what would you say about okay sir
firstly I know first thing I must start
under stop the description therefore the
particle object what it I didn't even
tell you what it was when I say particle
it begins at x equals 1 which direction
did it start moving at that point it's
not moving toward the origin how do I
know because the sign is negative right
the same thing so I start I started over
here and I start coming back okay so the
particle begins at x equals 1 and moves
toward the origin in what way is it
movies it getting far suck it and slower
how do I know where do I get this from
ok so hide the very beginning right
firstly the closer you get to the origin
because remember you're at x equals 1
and moving that way so X displace what's
getting smaller so the acceleration is
getting smaller right what effect does
that have on awesome
it's also getting much smaller faster
rate hold on what's going on this is
where you gotta be careful with the
acceleration and like slowing down a lot
because I look look with me this is
always negative do you agree always
negative right this is always positive
do you agree so this is always heading
it's always moving to the left toward
the origin but it's always going to be
slowing down it's always going to be
losing speed okay where does it stop
does it stop what would it mean for my
particle to stop if something's not
moving displacements not changing right
there's some point you get to it's like
you're not going anywhere now right as
time to aggressors at what point does
this thing stop there stop changing he
never stops he doesn't as T gets bigger
and bigger and bigger I mean it's not
changing very much but it is changing
it's a different value right this thing
never stops okay it moves towards the
origin always slowing down it's always
sliding down because the acceleration is
acting in the opposite direction to the
velocity okay
velocities negative acceleration is
positive always slowing down but never
stopping
okay now and ask one last question of
you what you kind of already answer in a
simple way but I want you to think about
it in a more physical way do you
remember when we were having a look at
this
we established oh look the velocity is
negative right and I just said to you oh
yeah of course it's always negative but
hold on a second vomiting how do we know
like up here right just because at a
particular point in time x equals 1
right how do we know it doesn't hop over
to the other side of the origin right
how do we know that that X never is
negative
how would you argue yeah what do you
recommend and so for that to happen for
me to even reach the zero at a certain
distance like stop essentially it needs
to be when you've proven here that X can
never be equal to zero
because of the way that this basis
function works so as a result it will
never hit sir and thus they will never
good posterity though ok very good
pause for a second see if you understand
what I just said right we we earlier on
we looked at this and the way we said
okay it has to be this case it can't
possibly be the other one is we argued
from when we argue from this single
point okay but once you do that it's
like we started here you've got a girl
from there this isn't like something
magical teleport article right it's got
to move from there to other places now
just imagine let's just imagine that he
wanted to be from there he wanted to get
to the other side of the origin good
point at the particle cross the others
on the road what would he have to do
he's my um he's my imagined axis right
to this the x-axis
there's one where I begin okay so in
order to get from one over to this side
right clearly he's gonna pass through
zero do you agree with that but what
happens at zero we actually already know
exactly what happens to the particle at
zero if it could ever get there it
doesn't move no velocity
look putting x equals zero in in there
no velocity but not only that
importantly any deceleration
so at the origin you're not moving
and nothing's making you move right
there's no acceleration acting to
actually change the velocity so once you
get there you're there forever there's
no way you can actually hop over and get
onto this side of the origin well it
never actually gets there right this is
just like this is just like 1/2 plus 1/4
plus 1/8 plus 1/16 it never gets to one
right it keeps on getting closer and
closer and closer but it never actually
gets there it'll be 2 if it was 1 so
therefore this is limiting behavior
right it can never actually go there you
could say it's time to purchase infinity
you if you want to think about isn't it
it would get there but once it does it's
stuck once it gets there it can't
progress any further because velocity
zero acceleration zero that guy's not
budging ok all right so I hope that
makes sense the trickiest things that we
found we're trying to progress for here
and try and work out what you've got to
get tied back into this right how are
you going to do that you have to
recognize there's time hiding within
velocity at acceleration so you just
have to know when to pull it out and
then calculus Tech's care of the rest